it's time for screen junkies boobie
fights what's going on everybody we are
here this is movie fights live hoot-hoot
this is not Percival Percival is in
rehab you know it's Hollywood and we're
celebrating Hollywood we all just watch
the Oscars did you watch the Oscars this
show make a lot more sense if you did
not just go along for the ride we got an
awesome group of our favorite screen
junkies and fandom folks to break down
the most glamorous night in Hollywood
let's talk about let's meet our
combatants will be first he's the head
writer here honest trailers and many
other enjoyable funny things Spencer
Gilbert
hello hang on my man how much you just
watch the show I mean maybe that would
be one of the questions
what's better than oh you know where you
love her she's the head of creative
development here you know from all over
sju and some really wonderful glamorous
hair to the party I dyed my hair just
for tonight just for the glitch just to
match the glamour of Hollywood I love it
looking good as golden as Oscar him so
no Maj to Eminem movie fights without
the movie fights champion himself mister
Dan Merle Marty the Oscars I love movie
fights I love the grouchy's but I love
not having to stay up all night more yes
no grouchy's because the next morning
everybody was extra grouchy and damned
with stamp editing all night long so
this is a happy medium right here and
we're all talking about we grew up
loving and watching the Oscars so it's
kind of a tradition here that it's it's
nice to break it down and watch it
together and our movie fights about the
Oscars is going to be decided by a
terrible twosome long Dan calling oh
here's some fearsome twosome very
terrifying yes lon Harris what's going
on brother the stars are out tonight
Hollywood's biggest night excited to be
here Daniel Radford I mean are you still
basking in the glow of hollywood's pat
on the back session they were Holly it
was very exciting the show it was fine
yeah it was fine I got to watch it with
my friend good stuff so we got lon on
the facts Danielle Oreo ardua is there a
chat going on will you be chiming in you
know there's a chat going on yeah we're
gonna be doing polls again yes any
questions about them there should be
some descriptions and how that's gonna
work down below or you can think us in
the chat there will be or you can think
us in the chat and we can tell you how
that's gonna work but essentially after
everyone's given their initial arguments
the polls will go up vote for your
favorite argument it's about the
arguments it's not about necessarily
which movie or whatever you like better
and then that will be our tiebreaker
vote in the case that we need a
tiebreaker
and then if that doesn't help I have to
vote so to help me be diligent yes and
Thank You Ryan O'Toole in the booth
holding it down making it happen
appreciate you man so we are going to
have five regular around questions and
then we'll go to the speed round the top
two combatants scoring will head to the
speed round and the first person to
answer to get five points the first
person to get five points will emerge
victorious
you know if someone could just like you
know she pitches shutout and just take
it and we won't go to the speed round
but that is a rare occurrence uh you
know let's let's drop that sick ass
package
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Thor alright question number
one this is a biggie let's start you
know what they saved the big one to the
end and the Oscars we're starting with a
big one what movie should have won Best
Picture you guys
I mean parasite won but we're asking
what should have won and we'll start
with player number one Spencer Gilbert
all right well in my position as the
Academy
I think the Oscar for Best Picture
should have gone to Joker stuff for you
guys we should have been doing more
Joker stuff tonight it got 11
nominations and I think for me this is
about respect
it's about respect because nobody else
in that room would still have a job or
still have a movie in theaters if it
weren't for comic book movies sorry
Scorsese it's time to get a little
respect they are paying the bill for all
of these indie darlings and foreign
films and yada yada yada that they are
so precious about they they owe it all
to the batman's of the world to the MCU
of the world and this one is a Oscar
caliber comic book movie they took
something like the Joker the Clown
Prince of Crime he's defacing stuff with
prints playing in the background and
they made it into a absolute knockout
class war fantastically acted mental
illness exploration it was open to
interpretation it was about so many
different themes
it had the best actors was recognized it
had the best score as was recognized it
was a cohesive vision and it put comic
book movies to their place at the top of
the mountain that all of Hollywood needs
to bow down to because it pays the bills
damn it oh boy is it just me or is it
getting a little crazier out there Thank
You Spencer hey what do you got you know
what put this man on a train and drive
him through Gotham because that is Joker
I just want to make sure that I'm clear
that you said that the Joker was paying
for a film like parasite
okay so keeping movie theaters I think
that honestly I don't think that you can
subjectively decide that one thing is
superior one piece of artists superior
to another but in the case of tonight
and only tonight and for this question
in the following four I am empirically
correct empirically implicitly all of
the listen Lee is correct and so was the
Academy for a very rare turn they did
not go for the film that campaigns the
hardest that paid to win they did not go
for the political move to sweep the
Oscars no they went for the best movie
and that was parasite this was a
historic occasion on for a number of
reasons one law in fact checked me on
this but this is a film that not only
won Best International Film which is the
new name of the category but also it won
Best Picture my hand we do drop you
around Ryan there's an honest trailer
commentaries frame up there
[Laughter]
almost and the fight I'm just gonna keep
talking about Paris okay I think the
thing that you would notice versus many
of the other films is that they might
have one or two kind of starring moments
or aspects to the film but parasite is
the one that this is great please I
think if you consider the facts you will
notice that parasite hit every single
element of filmmaking it is a film with
an array of brilliant performances
rather than just one the cinematography
is the star of some movies we may talked
about tonight but the cinematography in
parasite is also beautiful as
complemented by the editing the script
it has a sociological message that
speaks to its country of origin but is
also universal as can be demonstrated by
its multiple wins tonight it's
gorgeously directed it is funny sir
[Laughter]
[Applause]
keep going dan drop that we're gonna rap
dan and I are gonna wrap it up together
if you put it back on him instead of the
curtain I think that what you can say
about this film is that it has every
element that you would want in a movie
it is moving thought-provoking scary
emotional it is resonant and it is
downright hilarious in moments this
ladies and gentlemen is the movie of the
year so sayeth dan morrow thank you Dan
you know what the cameras in the right
place at the right time we gotta talk to
us what should have taken home the
trophy for Best Picture
all right respect to my Roth flash my
argument I am gonna say it is my
favorite movie of the year 1917 which
was the front-runner going into the
night it was the film that most people
thought would take Best Picture and
that's for a reason I
I love parasite land and I'm a fan of
Joker's well those are both there's two
movies that I enjoyed but I think when
you look at the movie this year that
encompassed what is possible with the
craft of filmmaking today right now
today not just not just in front of the
camera but behind the camera as well in
cinematography with Sam Mendes directing
it's not just a gimmick film which it
easily could have been the performances
in this film are brilliant and just the
fact that this is a film that is you
can't point to another film
that's like 1917 on the level of
filmmaking that was made in preparan I I
know on the level of filmmaking that was
made there have been plenty of other war
films plenty of other war films but the
idea of taking the war film and bringing
it into this way of of putting you in
that position of making it this one-shot
thing but not making a gimmicky not
letting the technical override the story
not letting the tricks of the trade
overwhelm the performances
to put you in that situation that is
very difficult to do and it's something
that you need a deft hand at and a
directing you need a deft hand at acting
in a deft hand cinematography down the
line to the sound mixers to the craft to
everything I really think that it is a
unique film it is a one-of-a-kind film
and that's the sort of thumb that I
think that the Academy would want to
recognize what movie in this year
achieved the peak of filmmaking in all
aspects and I think that's why 19th set
that's what 1917 is and I'll say and
I'll start off the counter-arguments I
think first of all comic movies aren't
playing Scorsese's bill Netflix's
Netflix doesn't need theaters Netflix
doesn't need these Netflix doesn't need
anyone to go to a theater they can play
their movies to empty theatres for weeks
on end it doesn't matter to them they're
in the awards picture so they don't know
anything to the studios or to convict
movies and parasite I mean I just didn't
go for the political move it's it's a
it's a movie about you know the current
class struggle that goes internationally
so I think that I think that it does try
to hit that zeitgeist and it does try to
hit that sociological importance and the
societal importance so I wouldn't agree
that it's just to be very very clear
yeah when I talked about the politics of
parasite I was talking about hello I'm
talking about the politics of the Oscar
campaign's themselves so just be really
really clear about that because I
understand your argument and I would
agree it's actually hitting on a number
of sociological issues that I think is
one of the strengths of the film eight
film is that it gives you an insight
into the culture that in which it's made
but it also translate it's an its
universal what I'm saying is that it's
historic because it didn't have to play
the Oscar campaign game gotcha in order
to sweep in fact the director basically
eschewed the entire ceremony and he was
like this is I don't know it's a local
award show he kept talking about being
drunk yeah one based on its merits
that's why it won a broke barrier is
based on its merits and I don't think
that can be underscored you're talking
about films that have at their center a
fantastic
but that's largely what it has and then
it's riffing on Scorsese from the we're
just incredible cinematographer just a
one-man show so to speak it wouldn't
have had the same resonance that it has
and that's what I mean by box-office and
like all pale feel to pay fealty to to
this movie it's not so much just
box-office though it made a billion
dollars it's the cultural resonance that
this movie had you could not escape the
Joker takes they were flying one way or
another this movie made you react
viscerally you either loved it or you
hated it and that to me are the most
daring movies the most important movies
the ones that echo out throughout
throughout the ages are the ones that
get you to like feel something not the
ones that you're just like oh that was
pretty cool oh that look really good
I enjoyed that I don't think that
anybody felt that first of all I don't
think anybody felt that way that
apathetic about either parasite if they
saw it or 19:17 frankly either parasite
was good I liked it a lot I think it I'm
not upset with that winning Best Picture
if I'm looking for a Korean con artist
drama with a creepy basement I'm gonna
watch the handmaiden
ten times out of ten okay you are really
really really missing a lot of the point
of social class Korean con artists movie
with a creepy basement how many of those
are okay fine then if I'm looking for a
lunatic going crazy in an urban
environment that I'm gonna go taxi
driver 1917 that's my point you're not
gonna is nothing like 1917 and that's
the point that man had some extended
camera shots and it was a gimmick it was
a gimmick
what 1917 does is it uses a similar
technique but it uses that effectively
and puts you into the denouement is
employed as if it was not a gimmick but
it was two things by 1971 it was uneven
I thought I was like at the edge of my
seat for the first half can we spoil
1970 Wow I'm closed up I will zoom out
hi
going on that's we're gonna go away all
right and then we'll restart so nice you
send me very uneven can't redo this I
can't read you now check once he gets
knocked out by the sniper guy and then
you just know or can I spoil it I can
spoil so it's in theaters we can't spoil
okay I'm saying past certain points in
the movie you know everything's gonna be
fine for somebody because if they're if
they're gone and watch a movie that's
just say the only value of a movie is in
the ending like the most striking visual
and and and I think like emotional beats
are at the end of the movie but my
credulity was stretched at the point
where he's diving into rivers and he's
like evading 20 different German
soldiers like I just checked out at that
point all right let's move to our final
thoughts okay everyone Spencer should we
do our final thoughts so we do final
thoughts when we come back or what hi
might make some slight adjustments to
Pratt for
welcome back to the party validation
alright so thank you for sitting through
that hopefully made yourself a delicious
hoagie or something and let's go to our
final thoughts again it was Spencer with
Joker often parasite down with the
nineteen seventeen Spencer kick into the
final thoughts look it's the movie with
the best performance as the Academy
recognized the best scores the Academy
recognized and it was a cohesive picture
and the fact that you could do that in a
comic book movie about social class in
America is just mind-boggling we're
gonna look back in five years and say
this is the defining picture of the year
and the one that was by far more than
any other the most resonant with
audiences I'm not saying everyone loved
it some people hated it in fact a lot of
people hate it but it affected you and
that to me is more valuable than any
other quality in a film Thank You
Spencer
Roth final thoughts on parasite final
bouts on parasite first of all all of
what just happened
is Spencer is to blame because it's
Joker stuff so that's an argument
against it but also watch the world burn
a very uneven film it is fundamentally
an uneven film that sits at the center a
really great performance that was
honored correctly tonight it's well shot
but it's largely riffing on Martin
Scorsese and if you want to see this
done right to Dan's point you will go
back and you will watch taxi driver and
you will watch the king of comedy and
you will see how a story like this ought
to be told this is incredibly uneven it
has really ham-fisted comic-book stuff
that does not belong totally in the
movie it has really two dimensional
characters as it tries to play arthur
very complexly they don't sit well
against each other it is not the best
picture of the year if you're looking
for a truly cohesive film that hits
every single mark of what a film should
and could be it is parasite and that is
why the Academy recognized it for every
single award that speaks to the film as
a whole because you couldn't give the
ensemble cast an award but you would if
you could in this movie you gave it
screen screenwriting you gave it
direction and you give it to Best
Picture Awards again 1917 which is a
film that I really really love was
awarded correctly it was awarded for
cinematography which is largely its
greatest achievement there are other
achievements in the film for sure but if
you're looking for
the truly holistically best picture of
the year it is undoubtably parasite they
got it right for once and I thinks Ross
dan I think that when you're looking for
a Best Picture winner you're looking for
something that's gonna stand the test of
time you both picked movies that are
about class in society and very much
about timeless very much about modern
class and modern society I don't
necessarily think who knows what it's
gonna be 10 20 30 40 50 years from now
we don't know what that's gonna be but
we do know is that a story like 1917
that is a very human story is a story
about survival it is a story about
fighting against the odds it is a story
that is told in a timeless manner that
is is very visceral and grabs you on a
human level and I think those are the
kinds of films when you go back as a as
an academy of you know aficionado and
you want to go back and watch all of the
old older Best Picture winners the human
stories are the ones that grab you the
most the ones that connect you on a
visceral level the ones that grab you
the most the ones that are sort of made
in the climate of the time I think lose
some of their importance which is why I
really wanted 1917 to win this award
because I think this is gonna be the
same movie whether you watch it now or
the watch at 50 years so now it's gonna
grab you in the exact same way these are
both these are all three fine thumbs
generally a move movies are that are
nominated for Best Picture are at least
good - pretty good sometimes you get a
stinker in there but I don't think it's
any one of these three I do agree that
Joker is largely about the performance
and I will agree that I think that movie
was awarded correctly and Waggin that it
is on Joaquin Phoenix's shoulders and he
does great but there are things like the
inclusions of the Batman stuff that are
ham-handed and and shouldn't be in there
and then with parasite you know I get I
got I can't argue with the fact that
parasite was a really well told movie
but I think that the uniqueness of 1917
the special craft and skill that went
into it I don't think it should just be
recognized on the cinematography level
or on a craft level I think that if it
were just those things and it did not
grip you in any emotional way then you'd
be correct but the fact that it has all
that craft and skill behind it and still
grips you on a human level you're not
paying attention to that stuff first and
foremost you're in the story and you're
following these characters and you care
about them the most I think that speaks
to the power of the
and I think that's why it should have
come out on top tonight thank you all
right time lon Harris what do you say we
get factual marble Joker to Ross when
she mentioned ensemble awarding and the
entire acting ensemble for Benedict it
did win the SAG Award this year for the
best ensemble first time that's gone to
a foreign language for many years to Dan
for 1970 British duel in World War 1
[Laughter]
want us to go ruin something with
history again thanks man all right so
strong arguments all around Spencer I
don't agree with your choice your your
argument you you had a strong argument
about it being an evocative film that
does not necessarily make it the best
film and especially like leaning into a
hated it and like something that is that
polarizing it's it's very difficult to
make the argument for Best Picture also
in your closing argument you called and
it was cohesive I would hope so so
strong arguments about why it makes you
feel which is an important and a piece
of art but it didn't at the end it came
down to 1917 in parasite for me and Roth
you had some really strong points and
saying calling Spencer's choice
correctly awarded and then Dan's choice
winning for cinematography and but then
Dan came back with just how visceral and
experience 1917 is and like it really
had my head spinning here but at the end
of the day I thought Dan saying that
that parasite was relegated to it's time
I feel like - what Roth was saying and
the themes of parasite are universal
things that stand the test of time I
mean the haves and have-nots I mean you
go through like the French Revolution
all throughout just histories and
cultures that is something that doesn't
go away and very close but by just a
whisker
I'm gonna go Roth on this one with Paris
on because I'm told that it's not
working Spencer really like I wasn't
really sold on the original argument
that comic book movies keep Hollywood
alive that's not a good reason to think
of something the billboard the MTV best
kiss award
[Music]
especially about you know like well it's
the movie that supported that one key
performance so I some good some bad
there Robin I think did a great job of
explaining why this is like an important
award a breakthrough award why this is
historically and culturally significant
that it won but overall and thought the
most just good arguments it turns them
here's why I think this particular film
was worthy of Best Picture I think I got
to go with Dan all right so that's one
one we're going to the polls to decide
Danielle Radford what do we got all
right poll box with 58% of the vote
it is parasite 1917 with the boat doing
that voting it's a Joker himself at that
point goes to the fact that Dan was
making the argument with me when we were
having I should have just left you think
that got the point but if there was an
MVP of that round it would be
ventriloquist admiral danielle any fun
comments in there
people are just super psyched that we're
back everyone seems to think we're
wasted oh and beer the entire night's
tired
yeah not been drinking at all Thank You
Danielle all right cocaine Oh
[Music]
so after one round Roth won Dan and
Spencer looking to get on the board all
right so you watch the show there were
fun moments there were cool moments
touching moments but there were weird
moments weirdest moment of the night man
let's get them here - okay
Roth what stood out to you as the
weirdest weirdo weird moment I mean
there was a lot to choose from in this
category and I think we all have some
really solid choices but I'm gonna go
with the one-two punch of the best actor
and Best Actress speeches oh and the
reason that I'm gonna go with them is
twofold one they're kind of like the JJ
and Rian Johnson of speeches and that
they were trying to undo each other
seemingly - they were both very long and
confusing but I think seeing opposite
things but I'm gonna get into that a
little bit more but and I think that's
true but the fact that I don't know is
partially why this is so weird and then
also it was unplanned weirdness where
some of the other moments that were
really weird tonight
clearly the telecast producers were in
on it and chose to do this this is one
of those beautiful moments that happens
at the Oscars where it's like it's a
surprise to everyone that they're all
crazy yeah so Joaquin I think was he
took us on a journey if we started with
your moment of nihilism for the night
and then we wanted to talk about I think
we went into pita land
I think that that's where we travelled
into the forest of PITA
I mean he's a big animal rights
supporter which I am too but he was also
talking about human rights and then in
vitro cows in insemination I think or in
cow insemination and then we went to
cancel culture which that's where I
think it really took a turn and the
movie took a twist in the form of his
speech it was just very very confusing
so I think he was talking about a lot of
things that are wrong with the world in
his mind yeah and then Rene came in and
just started listing things that we
universally liked I mean literally
she could have just been like ice cream
pizza orgasms these are a few of my baby
[ __ ] weirdly seems to be undercutting
what Joaquin said where she was just
like no everything's not broken this is
a list of all the things that we can
alright
we like firemen we like kittens awesome
Roth thank you for that opening salvo
Dan Moreau
uh yeah unplanned weirdness at an awards
show not that weird what is weird is
something that should be the most
meticulously planned thing being so
weird
and for me it is the very first thing
that we saw at the beginning of the
award show which is Janelle monáe's
number and so like this a pruder film I
want to take this apart piece by piece
first of all she walks out of the door
and within the first 10 seconds of the
Oscars we almost see a boob for the
Oscars like if you were gonna say like
oh what's one of the things that you
don't expect to happen in the first ten
seconds to the Oscars boob almost coming
out would have been top of my list
silently watched Janelle Monae try to
struggle to get dressed in mr. rogers
clothes on a replica set of mr. rogers
may be the 15th most influential movie
to come out in 2019 silently as the
music goes on okay
sure then she starts singing the
beautiful day in the neighborhood she
goes out into the audience and then just
like flirting with Tom Hanks and like
puts her hat on his head which is like
some kind of cabaret move but then she
goes back up on stage and by the way
what really weirded me out is I don't
know what's gonna come next but I see
Joker's just standing in the dark
silently what the hell's going on so
then she goes into a second thing and
there's like movie dancers behind her
like number one it's a little weird but
number two most of the movie dancers are
from movies that were not nominated at
the odds
so they have like the midsummer dancers
the Queen and slim dancers the us
dancers the Dolomites dancers by the way
none of those films safe perhaps for
dolomite should have dancers you also
have like nineteen seventeen dancers and
Joker dancers not films that should have
dancers like jangly World War one
uniforms now what I think of when I
think of 1917 then so you got the
dancing Joker's up there spinning around
then she goes that back out into the
audience for like some awkward celebrity
sing-alongs and like Leonardo DiCaprio
looks like he just wants to get out of
there
brie Larson's like a little bit of Ag
white and then just gives her a weird
look and then she lays down on the floor
like sings la la la la la into the
camera for 30 seconds and then it's oh
wait it was the weirdest thing it was
like - Rob Lowe snow white thing where
it's like what what what proves this
what's going on it got everything off on
it was just this weird awkward note I
don't I don't know what the hell that
was but it was certainly weird very
weird Janelle monáe's salute to the
urine movies thank you Dan
Spencer it was weird Eminem showing up
in year of our Lord 2022 do lose
yourself song from 8 mile from I believe
2000 2003 I think it's like 18 years
were a round number okay 20 year
anniversary is it the point 2002
yeah if there were the 20 year
anniversary of eight-mile sure if he was
back out there to do a duet with Elton
John okay it came at the end of a salute
to movies that took like pop songs and
kind of recontextualized them lose
yourself was written for eight mile that
was a song from the movie 8 mile it was
not they like found somewhere and then
decided to put in a film weird lon why
did that happen you fact check if
Footloose was written for house or
catalyst but there are plenty of
songs in that montage which I thought
the point of was here's how movies have
taken songs you love or or have made
these songs that you love from other
artists alright
fight it out y'all let me tell you the
two things I'm gonna expect on an Oscar
ceremony number one an actor gives an
actually gives a long rambling speech
number one on the list of things I would
expect number two
pointless montage with past Oscar winner
coming back to perform hit song that's
happened so many times do bring Barbra
Streisand if there's 20 years ago or 30
years ago it would have been Barbra
Streisand there's a guy that we were
bringing back somebody who won an Oscar
by the way was not present the night
that he won the Oscar so in a way it's a
redemption story I mean I'm gets to come
back and perform the song on the Oscars
which he didn't do when it won the night
long check where was Eminem the ninth
all the time on the Oscars they bring
somebody out and you're like oh what are
they doing there they're just
celebrating Oscars that's what they do
it just didn't fit and then I will say
this to all you're saying oh it was
planned weirdness and so on and so forth
the Oscars definitely said mm we want
you to go out and perform lose yourself
I truly believe that they asked Janelle
Monae what she wanted to do and she said
I would like to honor the the movies
represented I don't think the Oscars was
saying like hey let's put up all these
things that didn't well we're here
tonight to celebrate all the great
female directors revue show to celebrate
the Oscars show that didn't recognize
any of them they said you know I'd love
to hear some rebuttal and some thoughts
from you I gotta say dance I'm gonna
make a case for why your moment is not
the weirdest but is in fact the greatest
moment
because this ladies and gentlemen is the
Oscar Oscar singularity this is the
moment that the show becomes so aware of
itself and so aware of how out-of-date
and old-fashioned it is that it goes so
far as to recognize all the films that
it is not the Oscars it does not get
more Joker stuff than that it does not
get more great and it's like her singing
is always a delight I don't care what
she's saying who's dancing behind her
it's fun to watch her open a show
doesn't make it not weird over a lot of
weird when you consider the source it's
Janelle Monae doing what she does and
she's sort of subverting expectations
she's making it she's making a bold
statement and she's also and it's this
is the Oscars acknowledging that as much
as they are there to celebrate certain
films that night there are plenty of
other films that came out this year that
are equally deserving of a dance number
Janelle Monae concert this was the
Oscars bringing like recognizing films
and like if they want to say like here's
the movies that we didn't recognize they
can do that but to do it by like putting
them in costumes and having it in back
dance behind Janelle Monae after she
tries to seduce Tom Hanks before she
like puts a microphone and Lena
DiCaprio's face and he goes oh it's not
just the number it's everything involved
with the number nothing had nothing
clicked nothing everything was the
weirdest possum eyes
this thing was really good slim fit
thriller Glee I can't think of a movie
less appropriate to put thriller dancing
behind Janelle monáe's and like a really
like complicated deep thing about like
race in America the cause of celebrity
and their what the hell's going on again
pointless musical numbers and we're like
long rambling celebrity speeches like
Oscars like that's where the oscars then
the whole Oscars are weird
well those speeches though were
particularly weird this year I have to
say that you yes rambling speeches are
to be expected but you don't usually get
to back don't listen to your final
thoughts for back-to-back speeches from
two of the biggest winners of the night
a there seemed very confusing mixed
messages in one case in Joaquin's face
where he's touching on ninety two to
cultural issues none of which connect to
each other but essentially painting a
portrait of the world being in chaos and
then which is apropos for the movie fair
enough but then also ending it in like
we all deserve a second chance
one beautiful moment in that but then
Renee Zellweger quickly comes in and
just simply starts to list things I
think in order to encourage us to
believe that we all can find common
ground in again ice cream and orgasms
nothing made sense and she also seems to
be undercutting exactly what what Keynes
said there's I have never seen two
weirder speeches I set back to back that
way versus one of the most subversive
moments in Oscar history this
singularity ladies and gentlemen this is
the moment when Oscar became self-aware
that opening number and then a beautiful
tribute to a song that was not
recognized
[Applause]
and a half years later he's finally M&M
gets his moment I own it
dan is right around to you Spence
with the Rene in her series of listing
things she was listing hero she was
listening people that people admire and
the reason that it may have seemed
random is because I actually liked the
fact she was listening people across
various different types of interest
various different types of class she was
she listed Venus this route Williams she
mentioned people in uniform seem
innocent first responders he was
mentioning I think she was trying to say
that I was portraying somebody who is
admirable to is who was a hero to some
just like these people are and she
listed people that I think could be
across class and race and age and gender
and you know all that stuff people would
be like you know yes I admire that
person and relate that to who she was
playing and who Judy Garland was both to
her and to Hollywood
Joaquin I mean but what did you like did
you think what she was killing of you
every one of his speeches this entire
award season like what the hell is he
gonna say he's talking about private
jets at the Golden Globes and he was
talking about you know meatless burgers
and like of course he's gonna like kind
of go weird and rambling like that's him
that's always been him so I don't think
it's that unusual for him to say that
out of character alright that's not out
of character as far again as Eminem goes
a pointless montage with the past Oscar
winner performing a hit from the past
that's an Oscar trope it's been done
before if it hit anybody as strange or
odd I just think it's because Eminem you
know we're in a more modern time where
different kinds of songs have have won
Best Original Song I don't think it
would have felt out of place if Elton
John come out and done a Lion King song
know
that's what I'm saying that's the 21st
century's version of that it's just that
we're not used to that we're used to it
being Elton John coming out singing 24th
anniversary of that one with Janelle
Monae you had a planned opening number
that inappropriately paid tribute not
only to some of the movies that were
nominated but mostly movies that weren't
nominated and a number that was like if
you want to say it's the Oscars being
self-aware that's fine I think it's the
Oscars like it's sending a weird mixed
message as far as like you can't say
that this night is about celebrating
female directors none of whom are
nominated because it's not the Oscars
want to be self-aware then they can be
self-aware when it's time to nominate
things but you can't just say that
you're here to celebrate things that
you're not and then just again the
overall oddness bringing celebrities
unwittingly into this everyone was
caught a deer in the headlights it just
was it was a weird way to start the show
it started everything off on a weird
beat it one of the more bizarre Oscar
numbers that I've seen in quite some
time
so that's why I picked it Spence well
Dan I think that there's there's some
overlap but there's a big difference
between the people who put together the
Oscars and the Academy I think that the
people who put together the Oscars went
to Janelle Monae and said will you
perform for us what would you like your
theme to be and she probably said I want
to shout out all the female directors
and all the movies that didn't get
nominated that deserve recognition I'm
gonna work them into my number which by
the way it was great it was not 2002's
best UFC entrance punk lose herself by a
guy I didn't even mention his weird
beard died his weird Eminem's beard is
still weird to me it never looked right
it still doesn't
and then the cutaways they get nothing
you know this is always uncomfortable
somebody puts a mic in your face and
makes you sing but the cutaways to
Scorsese and Billy Eilish and all these
people who were like what is happening
why is Eminem here it was a weird choice
and yes
you talk about there's always a musical
montage and then somebody comes out and
performs but fundamentally the loser
self had nothing to do with what the
montage was the theme of the montage was
pop songs used in movies this is a this
might as well have been part of the
score it was very bizarre that's why
it's my weird choice
okay yeah go oh did you have one more
the speeches were fine thank you sir
Ilan Harris what do you have to say get
a factual past with a few facts so
Footloose was in fact written for that
film that Kenny Loggins wrote two songs
for that film he also wrote I'm free
parentheses heaven hopes the man was
that Kenny Loggins yeah I know I'm just
[Laughter]
[Music]
winning because you know when I heard I
was nominated I thought that was for
actors I was not sure what exactly even
MTV Awards all that stuff I just didn't
know what Awards men and this particular
award I didn't go to the show I just
felt like I had a snowball's chance in
hell of winning look up a thing Eminem
point Renee was listing people who like
Judy Garland
he said inspire people through the
generations
so she mentioned Neil Armstrong Sally
Ride Dolores Huerta Venus and Serena
Williams Selena Bob Dylan Martin
Scorsese Fred Rogers Harriet Tubman and
then in tow reaches a speech dude he
just
lon keep it rolling what did you think
of this round what'd you think of as
sort of weird for an Oscar ceremony
because all three of these things were
very weird
yeah but rambley speeches from people
winning Best Actor trophies I didn't
think I was like that didn't seem to be
like outside of what you'd expect from
the Oscars weird I thought the fighters
did a pretty good job of talk about that
ditto Janelle Monae and the weird
musical numbers with inappropriate
dancing about movies that maybe don't
serve that kind of expected for the
Oscars but I thought the best argument
came from Spencer as to why the eminent
performance was outside of the realm of
what you'd expect from a big award show
like this so I'm voting for Spencer
Thank You lon that's one for Spenny and
you know what I actually have to agree I
thought you made some great points Roth
in targeting those messages of the
speeches and like my head was spinning
but rambley speeches yes and yeah and
and Dan an opening and opening number of
the Oscars those happen and actually
talking about films that weren't
nominated being targeted I was in an
opening bit for the year Borat came out
I was on a beach with like five other
Borah impersonators with a fake
moustache and a Borat bathing suit on if
anyone can find I don't know it was
horrific but we all looked around the
room with the same Billy Eilish look
when Eminem came out and I think Spencer
and really now that that it kind of came
out of nowhere
so I agree with lon Spencer you get the
point
Danielle what does the internet have to
say all righty well it has been decided
but the internet had it had its way to
be able to affect the thingies 56% for
opening salute to movies 31% for mmm 11%
for acting speeches a lot of people in
here are not appreciated
mm slander by the way we're definitely
like I stand forever you and devon Sawa
congratulations thank you alright so it
is Spencer won Roth won Dan looking to
get on the board moving to question
number three Oh what was the most fun
moment in the night you guys listen
there was a lot of fun stuff happening
but only one can stand is the most very
model so Dan you know what I think is
fun
I think self-deprecation is fun I think
self-awareness it's fun yeah something I
didn't think the opening number had but
that's okay that's why and of course if
you follow me of course I'm gonna say
this cats you got Corden you get rebel
Wilson out there there's two ways that
you can go about it you can be a
sourpuss no pun intended about cats
failing or you can go out there and own
it and that's what they did they came
out they dressed in the cat's outfit
they said you know as members of being
in cats we know how important visual
effects are that's what's fun that's
what I like to see about the celebrities
it shows that they don't take themselves
too seriously it was actually funny a
lot of the awards patter was not good
this year particularly between the
presenters this was like first of all
just a funny visual gag it was funny to
sort of like acknowledge that yeah we
were in this movie that by the way was
supposed to like before it came out was
gonna be nominated for Oscars but now
it's a punchline they showed that they
owned it and even like I have the lowest
tolerance in the world for James Corden
for many reasons first of all mostly
because he's an award Steve but again it
showed that they owned the fact that
they were in a massive embarrassing
misfire
and I think that made this show fun
because it goes to show you that it's
not all about being self-important
sometimes they can laugh at themselves
very good thank you Dan
around his worn dispenser well Kristen
Wiig in my Rudolph can do no wrong in my
book they prove that again tonight you
really I don't know how I feel about
host Lesage curse but when they were
onstage I felt the warm embrace of a
double host right there I felt like I
was in good hands and like I just knew
they were going to deliver
and they did and that is fun when you
can let yourself go and say you know
what they got this they're gonna make
these punchlines land this is going to
be funny and it was it was brilliant
they did two awards I laughed out loud
both times that's more than we can say
for most of the entire show that
qualifies is the most fun for me
Thank You Spencer Roth you know never I
think in history has there been a moment
where the glitterati of Hollywood and
the every men like ourselves have been
more in sync than in the reactions to
M&M coming lose yourself 18 years later
I think one of the most fun moments of
the night for me was watching my
confusion be reflected in your face
Spencer and your face how you dan you
were there Danielle and LAN but then I
cons like adele dazeem spell it said
exactly like it's about Billy
Eilish so confused her face a load I
think needs to be memed
and that I think Scorsese's done all
through the audience we were one with
these icons of Hollywood in confusion in
shared confusion and I think that is a
very fun moment of the nights because
it's raw it is organic it is very real
it is unplanned you know you you you ask
LeBron James to come out and play
basketball and he's gonna play the [ __ ]
out of basketball you ask these two
comedic geniuses to come out and do a
performance at an award show that's what
they're gonna do there's no surprise
there yes it's glorious it was funny
I laughed I thought they were the best
presenters of the night even people that
come out in cats that's funny
they're cats but the fresh moment of
connection between us and those who seem
so far above you can't plan for that
ladies and gentlemen mix it up everybody
the only thing I didn't like about cats
was I thought that they took a swipe at
pun intended
the actual people who worked their ass
off on that doomed production for visual
effects that's a lot of people that's
like 900 people that worked on that
movie that were like oh yeah thanks for
rubbing it in stars like what a way to
throw the blame on us that's as much on
Corden and Wilson as it is on them and I
don't know this for a fact but I know
that James Corden has actually lots of
bad things after cats came out to lots
of people off-camera or or animals who's
to say I'm just saying it was gonna be
that projection and move to have a
stricken from the record say I can't
laugh at him because I know that he
takes himself so seriously so I was like
all right yeah you're doing the minimum
viable thing to make me like you I know
it was gonna be a joke in poor taste and
I saw myself and I'm just making it but
lon please see if James Corden has ever
as on record for hurting animals strikes
me as a friend to all put that out there
and then the other one what was your
pick the reaction shot is the reactions
for good I've seen better reactions
women seen better reaction shots within
the unfolding bewilderment of that
entire audience that matched the
unfolding bewilderment in our room you
do what I both agreed that Eminem was
insane you just got yeah we do those
reaction shots we don't love them
because we love em we we project our own
feelings onto those shots because again
it's not like there's worth the shots
that like when they put the camera in
front of you and like you know like yo
if you're sitting there with like and
they've done psychological studies of
this if you show someone a picture of
them just so I'm sitting there with a
blank face like this and you're seeing
something confusing you project your own
confusion lets you know there may have
been one or two that were just kind of
like I'm and I'm but like for that
instant for that instant that they catch
them I think a lot of it is you you're
you're projecting your confusion onto
someone who's just sitting there in a
war so this things are endless we were
looked like two hours into the award
show at that point Marco says he's
probably sitting there thinking like oh
boy oh geez what it was
mathroom how much longer is you know
it's not us projecting our feelings onto
these stars who no idea they're on
camera they're just sitting there like
there's this endless awards show I don't
think they took the swipe of the VFX
artist again they were just like oh he's
for all the crappy effects in our movie
they were saying that yeah it's as much
a critique on Tom Hooper's approach the
VFX his approach to filming the movie
there's so much there and again like
everyone needs to be able to laugh at
themselves that's what made it funny
waked Rudolf for the first half of
there's things I was with it but they
did the things they always do when their
host lists which is they bring
convenience out for a to award bit and
the second one went on that weird
acapella thing or whatever they were
standing ovation went on way too long
that went on way too I got uncomfortable
for me if I'm being honest if it was
just the first time that I'd be like oh
that was funny but they overstayed their
welcome
they gave him way too much to do they
gave him too much of the show to carry I
got the bit about the acting that was
fun but then they kept going and kept
going kept going and I thought with the
cats thing it was short it was succinct
it was self-aware it was
self-deprecating people understood they
got it here acknowledging the fact that
yes we're here to celebrate Hollywood
but we're also you know looking at this
very kind of embarrassing but also you
know in the end of the day it's not the
biggest deal that we were in this kind
of flopped this bomb and I think with
Wigan Rudolph you know it was an over
long comedy but that overstayed its
welcome that went on a little bit too
long and again with the reaction shots
during M&M a little bit I think of it as
dunking on people who do number one may
not have been feeling the way that we
think that they're feeling and number
two didn't know that they were on camera
I don't like it when they do that like
if you're gonna put someone on camera I
think you should have a camera there so
they know that they're being on TV
instead like we're kind of putting our
own interpretation of what they're
feeling on to them and I don't think
that's necessarily very fair I think the
the funniest bets are the ones that you
know we had two stars saying like hey
we're gonna make fun of ourselves we're
gonna have fun in the moment everyone
was in on the joke Spencer I mean Wigan
Rudolph to me were a of humor in a
desert of unfunny there were so many
people that tried to go for
and didn't quite land even comedic
Titans like Will Ferrell and Julia Louie
Dreyfus they they took a hard job which
is to have a bit that works two bits
that work I thought they did obviously
the subjective I didn't think it went on
too long and I think the audience agreed
it got one of the biggest pops of the
night and certainly one of the biggest
laughs so it was just it's it was the
most fun I had during a otherwise
funless show and yeah reaction shots you
know that's a it's a gift it's giftable
I'll have fun when someone posts that in
response to something I say later cats
yeah cats again they through do you
wanna say the it's not just the visual
effects sure they through Tom Hooper
into the bus it felt like oh we're
having fun with it but everybody else
like they there who's really at fault so
it didn't quite ring his phone to me
Thank You Spencer
Roth I would just say with cats it was
just kind of a 1:1 cat meow they really
didn't do much with the bit they dressed
up in like poor face makeup and then
yeah they talked about dunking they
dunked on their colleagues it's true and
like it was just sort of mean-spirited
and then what do I would say about my
Rudolf and Kristen Wigg is like they
just made everybody else look bad would
be my main complain about them like this
came out and made the rest of the show
look bad which is like you know you want
to be a team you want to pass that ball
you know a little bit and be a team
player but here's what I would say is I
think when you are at the Oscars you
know a camera is potentially on you at
all times and there's no that's really
not dunking on them and it's really not
in mean spirit the reactions are the
things that we give those are the things
that we talk about those raw organic
moments are the things that lasts we're
gonna we're gonna give Tom Hanks getting
the lights back up at the end for
parasite we're gonna gift Margot Robbie
being upset that people are being taken
off the stage for her film for bombshell
and we're gonna gift those reactions of
the fennel mint and confused confusion
because that is exactly what they looked
like and they were relating to us and we
were relating to them and in that moment
we were in a shared universe which is
pretty freakin rare when you're talking
about Hollywood in the rest of humanity
and it was funny because it was weird
and M is great we love in we stand in we
Stan Stan thank you Tom
all right long facts two facts real
quick that was Martin Scorsese's
daughter that was Cathy Scorsese and
also James Corden I looked it up yes oh
yes don't let a few of those I know
we're - I know we're - okay thank you
Bob Barker with the mic yes always a
good call that's um Ryan right there lon
okay for that suite Ryan land great
arguments all around though these were
three delight I was in the room overall
watching this we were all delighted by
all these things that we're talking
about
I thought Dan had a great insightful
take on Roth's moment in just we can
imbue those moments with anything that
we're thinking and just take it out of
context because we don't know like if
they just like got a text message or
something and what stick mind state
they're in but I agree we all shared in
the weirdness of mmm I'm so happy I got
to share that with you rock but Dan I
couldn't disagree with you more about
the acapella bit going to long that was
delightful like the whole thing but I
love your choice of the cats and wig and
Rudolph that they were very fun I mean
they I would love to see those two hosts
but as far as like the one pop like Dan
I think Dan hit what we loved about that
was just so satisfying when those two
came out and I don't know sometimes
comedy you know you poke fun at
something I didn't feel like it was too
mean-spirited I think they were
bathing cat baffling themselves in what
it was I gotta go with Dan and that cats
are just when they enter it it was like
so I'm going with Dan lon
yeah dispenser point I I liked Kristen
awakened by Rudolph I thought they were
fun I also didn't feel like it went on
too long it felt like the a capella bit
was like oh so that's happening is funny
but if it comes down to those presenters
versus the cats presenters I kind of
knock Spencer out I think the cats
presenters were the funniest
introduction celebrities coming out on
stage of the night just seeing them in
those costumes was a great moment so it
really came down to between Ron and
Danny really was sort of like it
interesting that was like one is the
most fun planned moment and then one is
the most fun like weird spontaneous
thing that happened that kind of brought
us all together and so even though I
thought the catch moment was really
funny the only time I left my seat
during the actual Oscar broadcast I
think I have to go with rock just
because I like the moment of I like the
idea of the most fun moment being a
community moment it was a moment that we
all kind of shared together and that we
will all continue to share as the gifts
get shared and as this Rican gets
recontextualize on social media oh I
would add one more fact Billie Eilish
was born in December of 2001 less than a
year before losers
okay so it's one for Dan one for Ross
Danielle where we at alrighty fresh
polls coming in hot with 51% of the
votes
it is cats presenters when 28% it is
rude off wit presenters and 19% our
reactions to mmm you guys can see it so
I promise I didn't rig this poll I know
you're all gonna assume that I did but
yeah so that is it everyone I many
people don't seem to get the cat's love
but I'll explain it to you if you give
me enough time Internet okay Danielle is
offering to explain to you hit her up
follow her and she will talk cats with
you all day long all right we got a
three-way tie everyone we're going into
question number 4 it's 1 1 & 1 of this
so here is the question they did turn
off their exchange yes we're in here
it's late no air conditioning for you
yes
all right we're asking you to check if
you could change one result what
category would you change alright and
back around question um before we start
with Spenny Spenny G in the true spirit
of Joker stuff I'm taking it away from
Joaquin Phoenix he's a fine best actor
choice but I thought he deserved it even
more for the master I think this is a
make good award for his best skinny
frightening weirdo role which was in
that film I think that we're gonna look
back and say you know what this was
Leonardo DiCaprio's best role this was
the way showed the most vulnerability
where he allowed himself to be a buffoon
to not be the cool heartthrob to be a
faded movie start to kind of embrace
some of the truth of where his career
isn't going but could go someday and how
it's gone for some of his peers so for
him to do that was probably the most
bold choice from him and I think showed
a range and a depth and a true honesty
but I don't I didn't know he was capable
of and I think that that will be five
years from now the consensus best actor
and best role of the year all right he
wants to go walking the Leo Roth I am
going to go for the animated
category not because I didn't like Toy
Story 4 cuz I did it was a fine family
story does not have a friend in you it
does have a friend in me in front of me
[Laughter]
[Music]
please continue sorry so I think that in
that franchise the third film they're
all great but the third film is the
masterpiece of that one that's the one
that it has an Academy Award it deserves
it law in fact check me on that but it
deserves it for that but in this year
there was a lot of other great kind of
original films and the one that I loved
the best and I thought deserved to win
was I lost my body and this is a film
that's operating on a number of levels
it's um it's really beautiful animation
it's got a really rich storyline it is a
sentient hand at the center of the story
among other things but it's a story of
loss and I think that it really works on
a for an adult I think it is a film that
you could show a child but one of the
biggest reasons that I would say it
should win is that the greatest thing
that the Academy Awards can do is bring
shine a light on films that otherwise
might not be seen and this is one of
those films that I think objectively was
the better film and objectively did
deserve to win and objectively it was
the better film on every level but also
it's a film that could have used the
boost from the Academy and Toy Story 4
absolutely doesn't need that alright the
Academy boost Dan I didn't pick a
performance or an overall film category
because I think it is heavily subjective
I went with a craft category and the one
that I went with was best visual effects
and as as I argued earlier while I
respect the hell out of 19:17 and I
believe that it deserved the awards it
won and more I would actually take that
best visual effects award and give it to
Avengers end game for several reasons
first of all the idea that there are two
major fully digital characters in that
movie that are integrated completely
into the film that have a lot of heavy
lifting and Hulk and Thanos with Josh
Brolin that I don't think you think of
as digital characters particularly
Thanos who's such a great
villain you see several different
versions of hem the way that they you
know Spencer you always say that that
you know motion capture doesn't go the
actor he goes to the visual artist well
the visual artist Scott the crafted not
just one version of Thanos but two in
this film so just on that level I think
is an impressive achievement then you
add the fact that you have a movie
that's jumping through time traveling
through time you're recreating other
movies you're stitching together
different pieces from different sets
from different times green-screen
practical bringing casts together people
that were never in the same room that
again alone on its by itself I think is
worthy of achievement and then even just
that final sequence that huge that
massive battle the fact that you're
bringing all these characters together
half of them are digital half of them
are real you're blending the rest adding
that to the epicness of the movie itself
all blended together I think that it is
not just impressive and I don't think it
should just be given for one or two
sequences but throughout the film I
think there's a lot of effects work that
you notice and a lot of effects work
that you don't notice going on in that
film and I think that I really would
have liked to have seen that work really
the crowning achievement for the MCU
awarded in this category over a phone
like 1917 that's not to disrespect the
work that was done in 1917 but I think
really to pay tribute to the work that
was done for an end game
all right care to mix it up everyone
please do I mean I never forgot that
Thanos and Hulk weren't real I mean that
was never that never tricked me we did
not have but a lot of people did you
never considered Thanos to be just a
character in the film sure to that
effect I think that the real test of it
was did I notice the effects or not and
by that metric 1917 passed with flying
colors I couldn't even tell where they
cut except for when the guy got knocked
out but otherwise I couldn't even tell
where they hid the cuts in that movie
the whole film was a visual effect to me
that totally deserves it and I think
that because it was an amazing mix of
utilizing practical and CGI
that it's a that it deserves the the
award which as I learned right before we
started filming is for both
legitimately feel this way about this
one is that you know Spencer and I were
talking about the moment in the film
where the plane crashes and that we
literally didn't know what part of that
was a practical effect and part what
part of that was CGI and I think that's
sort of the point like you were so fully
immersed in the experience and it's so
the work is so seamless that you don't
you genuinely don't know the difference
and I think that really speaks to the
level of craftsmanship that's happening
in that film and that's actually I think
much harder to do than work where it's a
character that it's okay a little bit
that you can tell that it's CGI because
we know that it's an alien but for you
Spencer I would just say that you
undercut the very argument that you made
at the top of this program when you said
point-blank that Joaquin Phoenix was
correctly awarded because he was the
best forward part that was part of what
we just you know you're just completely
undercut what you said the beginning
that's a new round right when for the
animation category I love my body as a
movie that you can use to teach kids
about loss but more than that about the
idea that they're supposed to put
pressure on themselves about who they're
supposed to be in the world it's a it's
a movie that works both for kids and
adults in that level it's the better
script better performances and it's a
daring film it's a film that should it
be awarded will encourage other films
like that that are out of the box that
are trying something fresh that are
innovative and frankly we just need that
we need that to be awarded and we need
to see more of that in this town but I
think you can make that same argument
around the film it's French
I think you can make that same argument
for the film that I would have picked
which is Klaus because that is a 2d
animation film I think we need more of
that I think that also film won best
anime no I'm confirming that I think
that you I think that you picked a
category were there almost any one of
those nominees could be just as worthy
as any of the other ones because Toy
Story 4 has also a lot like I think that
there are many worthy nominees in that
category so I don't know why that
particular one I would say like oh I
lost my body definitely needed to win in
that category taking it away from Toy
Story 4 I think you had a lot of good
choices for Best Actor I can't think of
another
this year that relied solely on one
performance than Joker and you know you
go back to in Rafah and I reviewed that
film the one thing that everyone was
talking about coming out of that movie
was Joaquin Phoenix and how brilliant he
was even people that didn't like the
movie we're saying how great Joaquin
Phoenix was once upon a time the
Hollywood Leos great but so is Brad Pitt
so is Julia butters
so is Margot Robbie so is that entire
ensemble cast they all feed off of each
other I don't think that's Leo's best
role up I might I think wolf of
wallstreet is something that highlights
his performance specifically more than
this one I think that Joaquin absolutely
should have won Best Actor but again for
Best Visual Effects it's not just about
Thanos and if you're arguing about
invisible effects there are plenty of
those and Avengers endgame things that
you take for granted thinks like Captain
America fighting himself a physical
impossibility achieved partially through
visual effects and integrated seamlessly
into the film people's costumes in that
film are CGI our visual effects you
don't even think about the fact that
they're not wearing these costumes that
spider-man's not wearing a costume
there's invisible visual effects in
every movie I think that 1917 is a great
blend but I also think a lot of it
number one was done through editing when
you talk about hiding cuts that's
cinematography that's editing that's a
lot of the other crafts that aren't
necessarily visual effects I think that
Avengers endgame relied so heavily on
having stellar visual effects work and
nailing things shots like Captain
America catching that hammer and and
getting that animation correct not
taking you out of that moment and
allowed the emotional moment to live and
breathe in that film and the scale of it
the scale of it was so massive for them
to deliver on that scale to deliver
digital characters digital backgrounds
practical effects things that you don't
even think about I just think that
accomplishment is mind-blowing it's
staggering to me and that's why I would
have ordered it final thoughts EVOO play
Spencer Gilbert I'll just say Toy Story
4 you know it's not fair because it's
Pixar and they have you know 100 million
dollar budgets but it's gorgeous it's a
beautifully animated film and that's
always gonna be rewarded you can't
penalize it because it's part of it
because it had you know the Empire
behind it it's it was it was beautiful
and
and animators take note of that the
animation for the Toy Story franchise
has gotten better with every installment
and they managed to do that again and
then again for me walking it's all about
this to me was they make good for his
previous body of work I think that well
I thought his performance in Joker was
incredible I thought leo's was better
for what it was and Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood and and that if you're looking
at Joaquin's gangly loner
it's it's her it's it's a the master and
then it's Joker so that's my spiel Rafa
so I just again I remind you that you at
the start of the show that said that
Joaquin should have won and I agree with
you you should have won that entire
movie rests on his performance and I
don't think that you are giving it its
due in this new round by saying that
it's not it's it's the exact same as the
others these other performances it
couldn't be more different
he's a very different character than the
one he portrayed in her and a very
different character than the one he
portrays him the master he this is the
best thing about that film is his
performance is him wrestling with his
mental illness is him wrestling with his
own morality that is very much the best
best strongest part of that film a
hundred percent and he deserved to win
it was the best performance of the year
DiCaprio was in a film great but he was
in a film that was more of an ensemble
film it doesn't 100% rest on him and I
agree with Dan there are other
performances from him that are equally
strong he's a great actor I would say in
terms of the animation my my counter to
both of you is that Dan what you said is
is that you agree with me that Toy Story
4 wasn't necessarily the one that should
have went one there were a number of
ones and other films in that category
that could have won that were equally
strong and I am positing that the best
of those for a number of reasons was I
lost my body but it was also because
it's an opportunity for the Academy to
encourage innovative filmmaking not only
that I genuinely believe that this is
the strongest most interesting film in
that category the one that has the best
craftsmanship across the board including
beautiful animation and finally I would
say that in your category Dan 1917 was
the one that should have won very often
in these categories and Academy Awards
they picked the flashiest film they
pitch
pick the most CGI they didn't do that
this year with makeup or visual effects
they chose the ones that actually were
used the best to immerse you more in
that world and help tell the story on an
emotional level I could not tell where
the visual effects were in this film
where they began and ended and that is
the point Thank You Roth Dan thoughts I
think that both of your arguments are
qualitative arguments they're subjective
arguments which every argument is every
argument is no but the reason I point
that out is that you know yours is about
the quality of one performance over
another and yours is about the quality
one animated film over another again I I
think that any one of those films could
have one it's not so much about the fact
that another film could have one it's
the fact that I don't see why that
particular one is overlooked or why that
should be taken from Toy Story four and
given specifically to I lost my buddy I
think that you can look at the work in
Avengers in game in my opinion on a
quantitative level not qualitative but
on a quantitative level just as far as
the amount of work required the number
of different kinds of visual effects
that were required from character
animation to clothing to compositing
green-screen you know yes the visual
effects in nineteen seventeen were used
to enhance the existing world and that
is one great use for special effects
however I also think that to create an
entire world to create an entire realm
and not just one but several across a
three-hour movie I think that is also a
really impressive type of visual effect
that 1917 didn't necessarily flex and
create in the creation of that movie
that Avengers in game did so when I say
it's a qualitative argument I think that
the movie did all the things that 1917
did well I think that Avengers in game
did well and on top of that added a lot
of other visual effects work that should
have been recognized by the Academy
thank you dan Moreau good arguments
everybody that is time long can you get
factual my man
so for 1917 the team created a digital
plane and crashed it into a digital barn
but then they had a big physical replica
of the plane on the set and they
actually blended those together so I was
like the Waterworld stunt show
exactly they borrowed needs first
explored for the Miami bisection
spectacular only other one is we we
discussed sort of Toy Story winning
so the original Toy Story was nominated
for original screenplay Original Score
and Original Song but the only Oscar at
one was a special achievement Oscar for
being the first feature-length
computer-animated film Toy Story 3 won
Best Animated Film and Best Original
Song for we belong together also by mr.
Randy Newman and it was also nominated
for Best Picture adapted screenplay and
sound editing I have a fact question for
you as Spencer said something to the
effect of it was like an achievement
award for Joaquin Phoenix didn't he win
for walk the line let me check
I don't believe he did no no Reese
Witherspoon did I said be way off bases
he was a nominee who's definitely
nominate on I may very well be sending
you on a fool's errand right now it was
toy story 3 you guys for the first Oscar
for actor Joaquin Phoenix he was thank
you did not win from gotcha great I want
you I roll this into your near picks
here this was a really strong round I
sort of agree with everybody like
DiCaprio was definitely my favorite of
the nominated performances I loved I
lost my body I thought Roth is totally
right that that deserves it more than
toys before but ultimately I thought I
just I get I felt like I heard so much
from Dan about what specifically endgame
brought to the table that he didn't feel
like 19:17 front of the table
and I sort of agree with his final
statement that the others felt more like
well I like this one better I think this
angle on this one is cooler but
definitely had the most over argument
for why this should have replaced that
so I'm going with that i agree with lon
and as much as the arguments were great
all around yeah spencer parter he wasn't
sure if he just wanted to pull off the
mask and say like now marketing agency
so that that call that into question for
me so it came down to Roth and Dan for
me and yeah this is a really hard one
dan I feel like in making the point you
might have helped Roth in calling Toy
Story into question saying you thought
other films could have taken that
victory but then you really that with
the the quantity of just the sheer
immense amount of visual effects in your
movie that is so strong but Roth you
really spoke to me and saying choosing
the smaller road less traveled and
encouraging innovation that is like I
haven't seen
I lost my body but you make me want to
see that with your argument so because
of that just slightly I got to go with
Roth so it comes down to Danielle it's
between Dan and Roth here
all right freshly refreshing the polls
and Wow
with 74% of the vote it is endgame
visual team I'm 23 I lost my body over
toy story and then two percent video
before walking
[Laughter]
[Music]
was amazing so much yeah and I was and
as Dan was arguing cuz I thought Dan
made a fantastic argument I was thinking
about Justice League where I was like
taking it out of the movie because of
some poor visual effects you don't
forget in that you don't remember that
there are big purple aliens yeah that
does really combines a fleshed out
three-dimensional character yeah movies
and you do kind of forget that you're
watching it through this artifice it
feels like Josh Brolin in defensive
Spencer we're playing a game we got it
like you got it yeah spencer bringing up
the master because Philip Seymour
Hoffman and Joaquin Phoenix know I
really dig the master all right so Dan
pulls ahead he's he's got to and Spencer
each have one and it comes down to
question number five here of the
nominees who did not win in the acting
categories who will be the next to win
an acting Oscar who will be the next to
win and acting Oscar and question number
five will start with player number two
Roth I choose Cynthia
areevo hmm because for a number of
reasons first of all if I weren't here
tonight I would be watching The Outsider
NHP oh hell yeah like the best character
in that movie I think she is what she
has going for hers and of her things one
she is good in everything that she's in
whether the work deserves her or not she
is excellent and I think that's the mark
of a really really really powerful actor
too is that she's incredibly versatile
you know she just basically I think she
got it tonight
during her performance I think she just
instantly got it singing but she's
really really versatile she's very very
different in each role that she plays
she is an incredibly inherent to
vulnerability that I think is attractive
and she's an up-and-coming actor and I
think that means that probably the next
big film that's sort of an Oscar
contender which people are gonna be
wanting her for directors are gonna be
wanting to work with her because she's
so talented is bound to be the thing
that catapults her into a botha
nomination and to win because she sort
of got you know what I mean she's like
taking the steps lead there all right
some thoughtful points from Roth Dan
what do you got I am gonna go with a
Best Actor non winner tonight with coma
loser he's the best actor non winner
tonight Adam driver mmm for a few
different reasons number one he is a
young actor who has while still being
the only actor paid his dues he's put in
solid Yeomans work he's put in good
performances and movies like silence and
then he's been nominated also he's been
nominated and this is my second reason
for why I think he's next to win I think
all of these picks are gonna win at some
point boy he's next when he's been
nominated the last two years so he's got
stacked nominations you see this all the
time the Academy nominates somebody one
year two year and then the second you
know maybe the third year they win they
win the award because the Academy's like
oh it's just it's his turn he's been
nominated the past couple years is not
only for black claims but last year he's
nominated for this year for marriage
story if he's nominated next year I
could see the Academy saying it's his
turn and then secondly or thirdly there
is this thing that happens every once in
a while where if there's a particularly
strong year where there's more than one
actor or actress that should win they'll
they'll do like a makeup thing the next
year so for example in 1999 American
Beauty Best Actor that same year Denzel
Washington Russell Crowe both had Oscar
worthy performances in The Insider and
the hurricane both nominated the next
two years the next year Denzel
Washington won for training day the year
after that Russell Crowe won or I think
I flipped those but Russell Crowe then
Zoe basically had three worthy
performances and the Academy the next
two years said okay we're gonna give you
the Oscar now I think you're gonna see
that this year because Joaquin was an
unstoppable force there was no way he
was not gonna win that Oscar that was
never in
question but I think you have a lot of
the Academy members who's watched
marriage story and watched Adam driver
and probably said oh man if it was
anybody but Joaquin we would probably
vote for him so I think the combination
of that the fact that he's paid his dues
the fact that he's been stacking
nominations the fact that maybe he had
just as worthy ears Joaquin this year
but you just couldn't stop that train I
think that means that next year he's
gonna make a movie he's gonna be great
because he always is and the Academy's
gonna decide this is his year all right
driver stacking the noms
Spence Saoirse I'm the conductor of the
Saoirse trainer show leader of the Roman
Empire pass on it so I was asking for a
good name for Saoirse Ronan fans that
was my favorite she's so great
don't you just cheer for when you see
her on screen I loved her in Brooklyn I
loved her in Little Women she is she has
an indomitable spirit she's young she's
not by no means peaking but is on the
upswing we're like she she's talked
about paid her dues she's been acting
since she was like a wheel ass yeah and
and now she's getting like big meaty
leading roles so I think that she's
intensely likeable she's super super
sweet and a great actress she was the
best part of Little Women and and I
imagine she'll be the best part in many
films to come
all right mix it up okay the best part
of Little Women and and and by a hair
because Saoirse Ronan is fantastic I
love both all of these actors is the
truth but by a hair it was Florence Pugh
who is my rudder oh oh she's going over
she made a very unlikable character look
likeable she makes bold choices I would
be arguing for Florence P with hashtag Q
crew we have the correct winner which is
Cynthia Riva when I talked about work
that didn't deserve her I was referring
to boss baby : back in business the TVs
great
so I would I would argue Dan that that
had had tonight tonight it would have
gone to Pesci
is who I think it actually supporting
sorry never mind take out my Pesci
argument and let's go perfect Adam
driver Adam driver I think the issue
with Adam driver is that he's almost
oversaturated at this point I think that
Hollywood's gonna take a break from him
they're gonna take I love him and I
think he's a really great actor and I
think he's probably gonna go do a lot of
really weird independent films like
Patterson that he did a number of years
then not a lot of people see that are
great that we will see and recommend to
you and then I think he's sort of gonna
hang back he doesn't like all this
attention so he's not gonna do the
campaigning that's really necessary to
get an Academy Award I think at a
certain point he'll probably bubble back
up again because he's a journeyman he'll
be working forever but I don't think
it's the next move I think all of these
people are in the position like you were
talking about to have been like they got
attention and they got a nominee and
then they're gonna get the win she is a
dynamic player I think she's out there
to win I think she's out there a force
of nature you could see her on the stage
tonight
magnetic nobody could take their eyes
away from her so I think the next move
in which she's in a film that has the
possibility that she's gonna do the
correct campaigning she's gonna get out
there people are gonna be rooting for
her just because she does have that
dynamism and she's gonna take the win
Saoirse is another journey woman who
will have lots of chances but she's
already had in a birth chances so far
sometimes people like what's new and
fresh Susan I think with Cynthia areevo
I agree she's incredibly multi-talented
he just mentioned science Bo she said
the boss made me think and II got
somebody who's multi-talented as she is
because it's not just winning an Oscar
it's who's gonna win an Oscar next and
the only reason that I would strike put
a strike against Cynthia Revo is that
she does so many different things that
she could go do an HBO limited series
and that could take her out of
quote-unquote the the Oscar race for a
year she could go do a Broadway show for
however many months they could take her
out of the Oscar race or out of one
Oscar season and Oscar season where one
of these other two choices might be in
contention because Adam driver and
Saoirse Ronan are largely now still
working in
I think the Cynthia Revo the fact that
she's so talented that mean she has so
many options for her to do so many
different things she did serious and she
was nominated this year that this year
but that might not be the case next year
next year she may do another limited
series and a Broadway run what I mean is
like I'm not it's nothing about talent
it's more about opportunities and who's
gonna get there first which is what the
question is about and I think that
there's two different methods with
somebody like an atom driver or a
Saoirse Ronan atom driver I think right
now it's got the hot hand and the
Academy does this a lot where they have
an act in the nominated once twice third
time it gets the Oscar he's got the hot
hand they're playing the hand they want
the new guy and that drivers is
establishing himself there
I think Saoirse is establishing herself
as the journey woman she has been
nominated since atonement I think over
ten years now she's been nominated
several times I think sadly what you're
seeing was Saoirse is she's the
dependable nominee that's gonna get
nominated a lot and then in maybe five
or six or seven years she's gonna get
the award because that's her time
because the story becomes about the fact
that she's been nominated so many times
and oh she's the leo
she's the Leo she just hasn't won yet
I'm banking on the Adam driver hot hand
thing with the Academy and I'm betting
with Saoirse it's gonna be the narrative
is that her time is gonna come someday
and then when she gets it oh man but I
think drivers gonna get there first and
I think only reason to get there before
this will be my final thought the only
reason he's gonna get there before
Cynthia is because she has so many
different avenues to to be talented that
I don't necessarily know if Oscar
winning movie is gonna be number one on
her list every single year the way that
it is with Adam driver and Saoirse Ronan
Spencer any thoughts
I would encode nice echo dance point
about Cynthia and I would only add for
Adam driver I don't know he's kind of at
a fork in the road in his career he had
marriage story didn't win an Oscar he
had Star Wars rise of Skywalker this
year he could he could just be like I
want to be a movie star at this point he
could make popcorn movies for the rest
of his career and star in them and just
be a global box office success and that
could be where his career goes and he'd
never be up for an Oscar again so that's
that's a risk with him and I think that
Saoirse she is the journey woman and you
know you can't win if you don't get
nominated so I think that she's she has
the best chance at anyone and is that
your final make this your final final
thoughts great Roth my final thought is
that I as far as Saoirse is concerned I
agree with Dan that it's probably gonna
be a seven-year long story
and then the story is gonna be how she
keeps getting nominated and eventually
she does win it'll be this triumphant
moment you can just see that playing out
I disagree with you guys about Cynthia I
think that she's in a position to do
theater in which she gets her peers
really respecting her and then she's in
a position to do a limited series in
which she is reaching more and more
people so we are rallying behind her and
then she's in a position to get herself
into an oscar-nominated movie and then
that's where the wind comes in she is
just the kind she has the kind of
magnetic dynamism that makes you want to
see her win and she's also just
phenomenally ridiculously dripping with
talent and which hurts when it comes to
Adam driver I really do think he's gonna
take a step back he's been really
reticent around the press he's been
really reticent to do a lot of the stuff
I don't think he wants to be in this
fishbowl much longer I think he's gonna
do the opposite of what you just said
and pull way back and do movies that are
frankly too small to bubble up to the
attention of the Academy Awards for a
period of time time all right Wow lon
take us to the facts oh no I only made
three films Harry it was only the third
film she's ever
widows bad finds it Oh Royale nice and
then marry only other fact a driver has
one movie already on top for next year
it's the english-language debut of I'm
gonna murder this guy's name Leo Karachi
CA are a holy Motors there's something
very weird movie it's called a net
driver stars is a provocative stand-up
comedian named henry mchenry sega maybe
he'll be nominated for that like the
Joker okay so if I was gonna go to Vegas
and place a place of futures bet on one
of these people to win based on these
arguments who would it be you know all
great arguments I feel like I don't know
Dan had the most just like tangible like
quantitated thing that I could see there
with the stacking the nominations thing
and then he brought in the the empirical
evidence of Denzel and Russell Crowe so
I love all these actors I want to watch
everyone I love Lady Bird and I love
Cynthia rivo and everything I've seen
her in the store but just on Dan's facts
I got to go Dan long everybody I thought
Ron had a very good final comment that
sort of did sort of poke some big holes
in both Dan and Spencer's arguments
about with Dan I actually agree I feel
like this was atom drivers big year he
did report he hadn't matter he was doing
a ton of stuff I feel like now is gonna
be his time to do like a play or to make
some weird indie stuff like this henry
mchenry thing he's working on and the
same liquid Saoirse like inertia i feel
like she's gonna be part of the Oscar
ceremony every few years we know she's
gonna do a period piece so she's gonna
be great in some indie thing
8:24 thing and she's gonna get nominated
but she's gonna be one of these gets
nominated every few years and then
finally which he's like 55 she'll win
you know something big so yeah I think
out of all of these Cynthia Remo is like
super hot right now has always momentum
and I feel like she's probably the next
one is gonna capture it so I'm going
with rock okay Danielle already fresh
refresh coming in at 58% of the polls is
Adam driver 33% for Saoirse and 8% for
Cynthia or revalue this is more than 8%
yeah she deserves more than a four since
that's okay you guys don't see bad times
of the El Royale oh yeah
movies
and then whatever boss baby think that
when Adam drivers holding his Oscar for
playing Henry McInerney right so Dan
takes that point it is 3 2 1 2 1 that
means we have a tire go to the tiebreak
oh man please
it's the latest I've been up since said
ok and I do not have the tiebreak or any
of the speed round questions
just pick a speed record time let me how
I have to find them because I was not
in the speed rap all right here's my
argument for why spending should be in
the speed wrap all right okay
here it is if you were fighting in a war
which British character actor would you
be most relieved to run into can we just
[Applause]
Hugh Grant okay first grant 20 seconds
on the clock for Roth oh you're throwing
this sir I mean that's really clear to
me because if you talk about Colin Firth
if you look at the movies that he's been
in just Kingsman alone he is the person
that you want fighting by your side
because not only does he know how to
kick ass with an umbrella and this pen
and his pinkie and anything else that's
available but he will be polite sir
about it he will be a friend to you he
is a handsome man and that for me does
mean something I'm I get the questions
you grant if you are fighting in a war
which British character actor would you
be most relieved to run into well I'm
just gonna interpret this as I'm in a
war movie because if I run in a Hugh
Grant I know I'm in a delightful romp
through some happenstance of fate and
he's probably about to ask me to dinner
and roses were about to fall in love on
the English Channel or somesuch
make sense if I see Colin Firth I know
I'm probably the guy that dies so Colin
Firth can give an inspiring speech the
person that he sees so that we know that
he is a hero sir that's exactly what
happens however it doesn't let you die
and you can't switch the genre just
because you know you lost with the actor
10 second rebuttal was very high just
Hugh Grant he's not like he doesn't
scream war to me so I feel like I'm
really late in the mood
so bad you got people like you ran out
here you can't suddenly make it around
for you grants there I can sir by the
way Rowan Atkinson yours okay okay so
Ross has won dan has three first person
to five Roth you need a strong run here
okay first question of the speed round
again shout out your answers and then
you get twenty seconds in the order you
answered and then ten second rebuttals
better fashion trend man broach or Cape
right you got 20 seconds to elaborate on
broach Dan you got cape on deck
yep we've seen capes for years and years
of years ladies and gentlemen but this
is a year of the brooch we had three
iconic brooch moves this year it was
Timothy sha'lame at his most shallow
main with a man brooch he first brought
in the drawers and then you know what
Elton came out and was like boom Xiaomei
I got your back brooch and then we come
to his beautiful lovely husband David
and you shall obey pendel a piece of
metal onto a windbreaker that's not a
fashion statement you know it says take
me seriously
Kate if somebody walks into the room
with a cape I'm listening to that person
I'm looking at that person at Cape is a
statement Kate's a bit on superheroes
but the fact that capes are coming back
has accepted high fashion yes please
there's nothing I want they are not
coming back they never left it's never
been a capelet Oscar I the 90s were a K+
time the capes have come back they're in
our Star Wars movies they're on our
Oscars brooches they've been jewel
jewels and ornaments have been wearing
on jackets always always capes are now
taking time alright so the question was
better fashion trend capes have been
around they never left that one I did
feel like capes were very prominent this
year and have not been in years past
that's why yes the question the first
place I'm going with them okay we got
one for capes one for brooch Danielle oh
oh
to clarify Cape Sandman brooch because
capes are gender-neutral as we all know
yeah this is really capes had such a
huge year this year
we're everywhere Coleman had went on I'm
really loving that big cape energy I
gotta say when soft boy he's in create
intimidation man broach it's the
beginning of something that we're gonna
start to see this was his Billy Porter's
tuxedo dress and I think we're gonna
start to see more brooches from here on
out big all right with the man broach
and vest really caught on it's dumb
vesti war and broach stocks on the
Nasdaq all right it's 3 2 3 2 question 2
what should have been the 10th Best
Picture nominee waves waves the farewell
waves and the farewell waves and the
farewell
we heard wave first start it off 22nd
start when you speak legitimately one of
my favorite movies of the year and not
only because it is a completely unique
film it's basically like a palindrome
where you start out following one
protagonist and then the movie turns on
its head the camerawork mirrors that
really beautifully and then you follow
this other character as the protagonist
by the through the end of the film when
it all sort of comes full circle
together and is the story of this family
time I'll agree that waves is a very
unique film structurally but I think
with the farewell you had such
exceptional acting by the ensemble
exceptional directing by Luke wing the
screenplay was great I think that the
farewell hit hit on all cylinders in
every single category that makes the
film great and for it not to be
recognized as one of the best pictures
of the year I think is overlooking so
many amazing craftsmen and so many
people on every aspect of filmmaking I
could say the same thing about weaves
only that I would say that it was far
more emotionally impactful not only that
if you totally get sterling Kate Brown
is in this film delivering one of the
performances of the year completely
overlooked he definitely should have
been nominated for Best Supporting Actor
and I think Aquafina should be nominated
for Best Actress I think that allows you
Jane should have been nominated for Best
Supporting Actress I just think that
there are so many elements of the film
that are exceptional that in a movie
movie contest of time all right
Lon Harris great films great arguments I
felt like broth with the talking about
the innovative structure what make waves
different I just thought that was a
little bit more compelling than anything
I heard from dance which was sort of
general like everything about this movie
was great you know good performances I
really liked how we're all sort of
attacked it right away in terms of like
what set waves really apart so I'm going
with wrong all right that's one for Ross
Danielle yeah I feel like yeah but both
fantastic movies and I really liked it I
felt like I on the opposite hand I
thought that they did a really good job
about saying you know what was because
you know there were great performances
this was a great movie front to back
from attacking it from all angles the
way that it looked the screenplay the
acting aquafina being taken seriously as
a person so I'm gonna go with Dan and so
that's one for each and yeah I feel like
Dan hit more points but Roth was
impacted by the feeling of the movie oh
I buy a hair I gotta go Dan
it is for two - for two - all right this
is game point for Dan question number
three of the speed round
which cat most deserved an Oscar will
yes Dan I am going to go with old
Deuteronomy played by Judi Dench
Judi Dench was there for a paycheck and
it could not be more clear than the
weird stare to camera at the end of the
movie he and McKellen of all the cats
and I will quote you Dan Morell in our
review he came to be a cat and he was a
cat sir
there was no
we deserved more on our very best day
than Ian McKellen's cat that is the only
person that was there to actually act in
the movie sorry Dan you just brighten up
it's a good performance but part of a
performance is knowing what movie or any
and McKellen was not in the same movie
Judi Dench got the tone of the movie she
brought the prestige and you actually do
take her seriously despite the fact that
she's looking into camera despite the
fact that she's wearing a big cape you
you buy her as the leader of this pack
of cats and that is oscar-worthy Ian
McKellen you don't take seriously no two
actors in that movie are in the same
movie there's none of them that are in
the same movie and that includes Judi
Dench who was clearly phoning it in Ian
McKellen came to play a cat phone in a
pizza order Judi Dench comes to play Ian
McKellen was there to screw around he
stood out he took you out of the movie
Judi Dench was there to sell that damn
movie and she sold that Roth reached
into my brain and pulled out exactly
what I was thinking that no one knew
what movie they were and that was such
crisscross applesauce going on in that
movie and she sold me on Ian McKellen
sets one for Roth Danielle I'm sorry I
you've lost me when you said that Jamie
duty Jen sold it it she did not voted in
she'd been waiting her entire life to
play this movie and I in fact I believe
it she used the reason why they were
able to get the tough town but they did
gay I appreciate your passion Ian
McKellen is the cat of my heart but Judy
did she came to play and Dan argued that
point very well so I got to go with that
one one wrong fundamentally disagree
with her on that Judi Dench was voting
that is that moment that Judi [ __ ]
looks into camera it's shocking deeply
Oh
[Music]
thanks for the memories but
[Applause]
skirt movie fights winter I would have
yelled at eunuch Ellen so fast if I had
she had a moment is shocking one and I
were next to each other of all moments
dan do you have an acceptance speech
oh I'd like to thank the folks at home
voted I would like to thank my my
wonderful opponents here I was actually
more pleased with almost every winner
this year and I feel like I could have
gotten so much more behind a lot of
these in past years I'm very happy with
parasite winning I'm very happy with all
of the top awards really there were very
few even visual effects that's the one
that I really do I would have given that
to end game but I'm not gonna sit here
and you know stew about 1917 it was a
very very uninteresting show but I was
actually quite happy with most of the
winners so it's just fun to sit here and
do this again thank you Dan thoughts
yeah this was fun I I mean I think like
you Dan we all come in here and know
that we these are subjective movies and
we love them all and honestly I wasn't
really displeased with any of the
winners this year either but it's fun to
screw around with you guys and talked
about cats yeah yeah yeah Spencer thank
you for getting a babies happily with
this but yeah you know I wish the Oscars
were worse so that this joke could have
been better but you know we worked with
what we got
they were fine this was fine this show
but they could have [ __ ] the bed blonde
and Danielle awesome thank you for
holding it down on the couch thoughts
shoutouts be back here in exactly 12
hours our tutor was fighting boy I'm not
gonna say anything I'm sweating so much
out of these lights I'm just home it's
very warm big company see it around
round two yeah thank you for bearing
with us Thank You Ryan for holding it
down and taking care of our good man
Ryan O'Toole in the booth and yeah
thanks again for watching
hoot hoot everybody I like I don't know
why I'm clapped
you